Brad Pitt breaks his silence about his
divorce from Angelina Jolie and we have
a glimpse into Angie's new world who
really is in her inner circle helping
the actress navigate this divorce we're
are Brad and Angelina it's been eight
days since Jolie filed for divorce it
was last seen in Croatia on September
2nd Angelina September 9th in Jordan
it's believed Jolie is in seclusion at
this 12 million dollar beachfront rental
in Malibu
last night the actress apparently
ordered pizza for an all for her six
kids and Pitt spoke out on the divorce
today he said he's skipping a film
screening tomorrow night because quote
I'm currently focused on my family
situation and don't want to distract
attention away brats ex Jennifer Aniston
has not commented on the split but her
husband Justin throw just did while to
impress for his new movie the girl on
the train the row said quote as a child
of divorce all I can say is that's
terrible news for those children and
that's all you can really say and today
we're learning more about Angelina's
inner circle Angelina's two closest
friends right now are ladies named are
Minka helic and Chloe Dalton they are
both foreign policy experts over in
Great Britain and have been advising
Angelina on her work in politics and
human rights issues around the world
Angie doesn't make any decisions without
these two a source close to the Pitt
Jolie situation says that the two women
advising Angelina have been fueling the
actresses aggressive approach against
Brad since the beginning next Angie vs.
Brad the legal battle both stars are rep
by Hollywood heavyweights just last week
Brad hired land Spiegel who represented
Michael Jackson Angelina has retained
Laura Wasser who was team depth during
his ugly divorce from Amber Heard Wasser
has also worked for Maria Shriver Khloe
Kardashian Drew Barrymore and many
others
she told et the divorce process can be
emotional for her clients there is
crying and there is screaming and there
is yelling and then hopefully there is
the epiphany moment where they say you
know what I want to get this done
Livan Angelina Jolie came to Wasser many
years ago when she was divorcing Billy
Bob Thornton there's also custody issues
she was highly successful then and she
went back again to the same power broker
former prosecutor Michael kraut is
familiar with both attorneys he says
Brad's counsel will take a low-key
approach Spiegel is gonna be much more
discreet and being to be reactionary
some point and gonna be very protective
of Brad Pitt
remember that Spiegel and Wasser have
got battled head-to-head on Charlie
Sheen's case many years ago and so
they're familiar with each other
strategy and it's about working this
case out
[Music]